when you ask people what makes a great
horror film many say it's the thrill of
being scared each year horror films make
millions by incorporating quote an
overwhelming and painful feeling caused
by something frightfully shocking
terrifying or revolting in fact the
actual number of horror films produced
worldwide have increased exponentially
since the 1930s and with recent
successes such as it and get out it
looks like that trend will continue but
what separates a good horror film from a
great one is it the amount of blood your
scares of terrifying villain although
those are indeed elements to some horror
films they aren't the most important in
fact many horror films today forget the
cornerstone of great filmmaking that's a
great story but first let's briefly look
at where horror films too often go wrong
the jump scare has become a common
tactic used in many films but its
reliance for cheap thrills in modern
horror can sometimes become a hindrance
according to where's the jump com an
online database which tracks the number
of jump scares and movies the top three
films with jump scares average is
staggering 30 jumps per film that's one
jump every three minutes not
surprisingly they also averaged a dismal
4.8 on IMDB and how many times have we
seen something like this
[Music]
or something like this no no the service
your sucks
horror movies today rely far too heavily
on these cliches they're stale
uninteresting and don't bring anything
new to the genre in other words they're
derivative it's part of the reason many
claim the slasher film is dead
everything's been done to death
cliches take us out of the movie and
thus out of the poor finally many horror
films especially Hollywood horror
focused too much on gore or shock fede
alvarez --is remake of Evil Dead is a
good example story takes a backseat to
over-the-top gore at the same time
losing the lovable charm of the original
that endeared us to Bruce Campbell's ash
Williams but what I really want to get
to is an element often glossed over in
horror writing that's empathizing with
the character as I like to say scaring
is caring 20 17s get out is a great
example of empathy driven horror in it
Jordi Peale has created several
empathetic characteristics in the
character of Chris Washington now it's
important to know the difference between
empathy and sympathy because far too
many horror films make the mistake
relying too heavily on sympathy that's
thinking because something bad is
happening as someone will automatically
care about them not true when we
empathize with the character we're
relating to them we are connecting
connection equals investment
whereas sympathy is disconnection no
investment how many hundreds of horror
films have you seen where a character is
being brutally murdered and you sit back
and go damn that sucks but there's no
investment at all which leads me to a
great example of empathy driven [ __ ] 27
teens get out remember
empathy equals connection so how does he
do this first Jordan puts Chris in
situations we can all relate to and what
better situation than meeting your
partner's family for the first time
we've all been there
awkwardness the tension reckon we
connect second Chris cares about his
girlfriend he loves her and wants her
white upper-class family not to be
caught off guard when he shows up he
knows that pleasing her family will
please her third he has a bad habit that
he wants to quit you smoke Chris we've
all at one time or another wanted to
quit something whether it be drugs
alcohol or even just to lose a little
bit of weight regardless we connect
there are many other such
characteristics apply to Chris such as
his love for animals dream of becoming a
photographer but what peel does
fantastically here is link those
empathetic characteristics to the story
itself meeting the family provides the
backdrop or the context for which the
story takes place and he does that out
of love for his girlfriend and quitting
smoking becomes a dramatic tool to get
him to agree to the hypnosis this is
character driving story but the real
danger for Chris team doesn't even begin
until 65 minutes into the movie by that
time we've connected with him on such a
level that the scares and war of the
final act are greatly intensified we
care about him we want to see him
survive and this is born out of our
empathy out of our connection so the
next time you find yourself dozing off
to a horror flick ask yourself this
question am i connecting with the
character if not you may just want to
see them die for the fun of it instead
of for the thrill of it as Tom's shown
from The Guardian puts it for today's
sophisticated audience it's not all
about jump scares the best horror movies
keep playing even if you shut your eyes
hey if you like what you watch make sure
to subscribe and leave a comment below
[Music]